this episode brought to you by gray
block pizza gray block get that hitter
[Music]
I got that short neck baby there we go
nasha nasha
[Music]
yeah come on yes go
it's never too late to come
[Music]
you go boy so don't you hesitate to come
over it's never too late to come over
time slips away from you and me now
that's that deed that's that late night
text you know that you could drop into a
ladies
text box hey it's never too late to come
over and then she text back yeah it is
okay
it's 304 it's 3 o 4 a.m. and Mama just
you know mama just hit put a chip you
know hit a chili dog in her throat and
she just put some lotion on her arms and
neck so you need to shut it down and
contact me during regular human hours
and that's you that's from about 11:00
a.m. to 8:00 p.m. if you're texting
women or men outside of those hours you
know you shouldn't be probably you know
I think that's nonsense Yule hours you
know if you start all right you know
maybe up to about 11 p.m. maybe I would
say 11 a.m. or 11 p.m. because you start
getting greedy out there 1:00 a.m.
efficient one of my old moves is I would
uh I would just text a blunt I would
open up a girl's you know text name on
my SMS and then I would just press the
spacebar one time and then I would just
send that so it was just like sending a
bubble nothing no words anything and you
just blast that bubble out there and
then see if she won't stop you know
catch that thing in her mouth and so
that's the way you could just be fishing
just throwing bubs into the air you know
you're just tossing them those empty
spheres out there and seeing if
anybody's bitin seeing if they got any
bad little law I seen if they got any
bad little little ladies biting on them
on them hope bubbles people hoping for
somebody to touch say crotch late at
night isn't it wild how your crotch just
becomes this beacon of hope isn't that
correct
I mean it for men it does I don't know
what women are doing out at these hours
but for a lot of men your crotch just
becomes as
beacon of hope at like about I think
maybe 11:40 p.m. your cross just starts
sending off this sonar signal like you
know it's like a it's like a dolphin
just like a coochie dolphin just kind of
you know just milling around out in the
atmosphere looking for looking for some
affection look for somebody to come over
and pet it cuz a crotch think about this
I'm a crotch is just like a puppy all
the crotch won't somebody to do is just
to come rub on it think about that and
that really flares up about 11 p.m. and
I don't know what that if that's called
if that's a syndrome or what that's
called but it's undeniable that that
happens that's undeniable that that
happens I want to say happy Memorial Day
to anyone and everyone who's involved
with our Armed Forces I want to say you
know offer a prayer up for anyone who's
lost a family member in in in in service
to this country
you know Memorial Day or decoration day
that's what they called used to call it
or some people still call it they
started up after the Civil War just
honoring those who have fallen and it's
a Brit you know it's just the bravery
there for me it's just I've said this
before one of my biggest regrets is that
I haven't served you know I've done
something gotten to do some tours for
the military over the years and going
over and seeing what these men and
women's lives are like and and it's just
fascinating it's fascinating to know
sure it's a job you know sure there's
you know people are paid for it but it's
a
it's a brave it's a bravery that I don't
possess you know it's a commitment that
I'll you know wasn't willing to make and
you know my hat's off in my heart open
to those who have lost a loved one who
was in service to our country and God
blesses those people you know that's
that's so brave I was just at home this
weekend actually I went to a high school
reunion and we had a gentleman from our
class who who who lost his life in
Afghanistan and and it was just
interesting hearing people talk about
him and share stories and you know so
I'll be thinking about him this weekend
and I'll be over probably the cemetery
tomorrow they have a beautiful Cemetery
near me
I think it's Los Angeles Memorial what
is that and I go over there on Memorial
Day and check it out and they do some
beautiful services and there's just all
the flags on the grape headstones and
it's a it's a pretty marvelous time
before we get into today's episode you
know a lot of people been asking me what
about trickling Mickey you know he got
them new hitters he got them new baby
bags in his chest you know and if you
don't know about Mickey
Mickey got involved earlier with the
show and we communicated with him and
he's been suffering off from cystic
fibrosis since he was which sounds like
a which sounds like a snack let's be
honest that sounds like something you
would get at a health food store you
know like oh Janet just got a new a new
bag of a cystic fibrosis remember like
well I guess it's movie night at her
house okay but it's a lung disorder and
it's an ailment and it can it can kill
you
and and so Mickey's been on this
transplant list for awhile and he
finally got them new baby bags and so I
want to check in with that I want to
check in with him right now
and and and just give you guys an update
via him that's the first time I've
talked to him since he got out of his
transplant and got those new those new
hitters that he got let's check in with
Mickey now let's see what's going on see
how them new the new air titties are
holding out
hello hey mickey you know feei the gone
man what up bro yeah new headers bro you
got them new fresh air duffles on baby
boy man hey man life is no good brother
it's so good to hear your voice man dude
you too man you sound like a day
honestly - you sound like an adult now
dude
you know it's great usually real fast do
my diet friends haven't hooked up to my
lung flying guy laughs right now like
literally I'm it's a silent laugh but I
am an adult I'm an adult now and I went
uh dude I weigh 118 pounds but I'm still
an adult Dan you come and he's that
lighter he's that light adult but look
out you know look out you got some
weight to put on so you don't your
diaphragm isn't hooked into your new
lungs yet it takes a little bit of
strengthening man like little actual
conditioning because those are those
nerve endings you know got severed and
so that's why yeah man it's like nothing
really comes I'm laughing over you I
really am trickling what give this with
those severed nerves man you got that
you coming in with that soft chuckle
right now cuz you can't do you can't
really go ahead you can't really go hard
in the humor paint yet can you know man
well you know writing of course is we
talked about but I'm in yeah yeah it's
been good the last we'll come back it'll
come back there you go man yeah it's
gonna be such a gift when it does dude
so I mean you're back like you are where
were you at before like out of 10 and
where you're at now out of 10 and so it
is really funny man you know when we
talked like three weeks ago I want to
say four weeks maybe um you know I was
like I think I told you like maybe an
8.5 in life right you're not a ten yeah
dude this is like you know not to be all
hokey or whatever man yeah it's like it
can out of 10 if not 15 and then dude
every day
you're out there huh every day is
beautiful dude
so dude let me here so you got those new
lungs now the person that um that
donated them to you this would that
person was a they overdosed is that
right that's true man yeah I said that
over text you know in the sense that
this was what was considered a high-risk
transplant meaning that the donor had
been using intravenous drugs and also
spent a little bit of time in jail Oh
ring it boy you got a real G inside of
you now dude I got my street credibility
went up about a hundred percent I leave
double what I'd normally had you know
dude you got them dirty moist
you got them dirty moist duffels living
in yours in your sternum now dude this
is gay right Jane no is there in wrote
go on I want it I want to tell you real
thousands right after Cinco de Mayo too
so you know those parties happen men and
you know I think I got you know what you
told now I got I think I'm gonna reach
out to the family and like about nine
months or so mm-hmm it's it's fresh for
him right but what I'm saying is I think
I got a little bit of you know I got a
little bit of some flavor it's all
saying me these days man oh really if
like you could dance better absolutely
of course
I'll give breathe better you definitely
know how to be about it wow man I can't
believe that can you whistle give me a
whistle man would hey let's do that yeah
we shutting down all these birthday
cakes boy trickling got them riding bags
give me that cat call can you give me a
little bit of cow hey you're gonna [ __ ]
a cousin if you keep it view it you
gotta you gotta hurt you need to turn
that back baby
what about a yodel can you give me a
yodel Lamar dude yodel that's gonna be
too hard and we still singing right now
I'm still singing a little bit alia Alia
first get my doubling back up you know
dude that's so awesome man so you're
back do you feel how do you feel right
now then I feel incredible in all levels
I'm
so focused on my recovery in regards to
my nutrition and my my sleep and also
exercise max it's not like four times a
day I told you our way
118 it's because of the fact that the
transplant surgery takes a lot of your
muscle out of you man a lot about
protein to recovery what a thief to a
lot of these doctors men they get inside
when you're just them I'm not joking
they're just like it's like whenever
you're building a home in a sketchy
neighborhood you have a lot of addicts
will sneak in at night and bust out the
copper piping at night and melt it down
and sell it so you know what happened in
there I woke up here's listen dude steel
man I'm a clean gentleman you know yeah
I you know I was I went there preparing
I shaved and I you know I I can't clean
yeah I woke up I realize these guys also
shaved my armpits and I was like oh yeah
that's the one thing I forgot Wow yeah
this you never know when you're on that
table you're right now who knows what
they're gonna do dang you know you could
they could do anything man I might go in
for a goin for a treatment just cuz I
got a lot of body hair well honestly
would not even mind hey you know having
somebody put me to sleep and take it off
of me but man I'm so happy for you dude
and I'm so uh I'm just so grateful that
you let us be a part of a little bit of
this experience dude dude I if I can
gush out to you in in the this past
weekend family man I felt God man eyes I
thank you so much for being a part of it
I'm happy to be a part of it everything
as well but the amount of people that
have reached out to me man I just thank
them Thank You Man and it's been a truly
it's been a truly beautiful experience I
say that with the utmost utmost truth
man well same here man I mean there's
been moments where like you know
probably little moments in a lot of our
days you know myself and and the
listeners were you know something we
didn't want to do or something we didn't
want to you know take a moment of or you
know we didn't want to try and you know
and then having you know some
inspiration having that you know you
have an angel on one shoulder and a
devil on the other but then you got a
trick lung Mickey hanging off your
earlobe
you know sometimes we hear your voice
and it tells us to get it going so yeah
thank you so much we could have to get
you in studio sometime this year dude I
would love nothing more man yeah yeah in
touch men and get that recovery process
in order and you know I'll be putting
out my stuff and yeah they start singing
but I'm gonna see you in a choir I'm
like scuba diving dude I want to see you
if somebody can't like CPR do you should
be giving CPR to people who don't even
need yeah it's funny mention of my
birthday I want to go skydiving yeah I
think you just you just did something
like that right did minute and it was a
blast and now I get to do that so you
know this this summer after dryly
recover a little bit we go skydiving so
you'll see me out there man oh I'll look
up there and see I'll look for you dude
well look thank you so much dude
congratulations you know just moving on
with this battle with cystic fibrosis
and you got them new lungs dude and you
just get out there and keep taking hits
off the world bro all right Mick I'll
talk to you soon man I mean let's look
back at your butt man and that's one of
our mascots right there Mickey you know
and that's just so inspiring and you
know I met Mickey because you know my
sister was born with biliary atresia she
when she was born she had a rare liver
disease that affects like I think almost
one and a half million children at the
time and so throughout my childhood she
was you know having to be shipped around
to these different hospitals and she
would come home and be all you know
scarred up and you know she was like
this green or she had like a green tint
or jaundice kind of or a you know purple
even sometimes really Mardi Gras colors
honestly in Louisiana you know even if
it's a sick baby people get excited if
you have green purple and gold it'll be
like well look she's sick but you know
that's a Mardi Gras colors but I
remember that and just and then whenever
we started getting in touch with Mickey
it just really you know it's stuck in a
special place with me because I didn't
get to see my sister a lot when we were
growing up
because you know it's just it's it's
it's amazing what illness does you know
it's just amazing what an infection it
is and how it can resonate throughout a
family and it can bring people together
and it can take people apart and I guess
that's just all facets of life you know
I didn't mean to get off on a weird
tangent already but uh this whole
existence is a weird tangent isn't it
isn't this a weird tangent that we are
on thank you guys for being here with me
today a happy Memorial Day you know
I went home for my high school
graduation and I wasn't sure up until
really the last minute if I was gonna go
and I was like I don't know should I
should I not and and part of me didn't
want to go because I was like you know I
got offered to do a show on Saturday
night with with Joey Diaz and with Joe
Rogan at the Ice House in Pasadena and I
was like and I was like man this is this
is a great opportunity it's a fun show
you know I love both these guys I'm
always honored to be around them and
then I just like you know but if I don't
go to this reunion am I gonna regret it
and I also didn't want to you know I
wanted to just stay in touch with kind
of you know where I where I'm from I
guess somewhat I didn't want to I didn't
want to I don't know I wanted to maybe
look see some people's eyes that I
hadn't seen in a long time and maybe a
memory would spark up inside them you
know wanted you know to take a couple
puffs off that nostalgia because I'll
smoke a fricken boy I'll smoke our whole
rock of nostalgia I'll you know I love
nostalgia
I love taking this free time warp you
know into a moment you know it's crazy
sometimes how it you know you can see
somebody or smell something and suddenly
you're in a you're in 15 years earlier
in your life and you know people say
well we don't know if we can time-travel
I say well then you know you didn't walk
into a cafeteria and smell some green
beans that took me back to my
to my neighbor's house because I [ __ ]
one hit off those uh those hairy Cove
errors and that's French for green beans
and [ __ ] I'm time traveling but I guess
I did yeah I didn't want to have that I
didn't want to miss the opportunities of
that nostalgia and then also I figured
you know if I go if I show up at the
reunion you know maybe somebody else is
excited to see me and so you know in the
end i'll you know i went and i had a
nice time and they had all types of
people there they had one dude this
fellow makes prosthetics and he showed
up so that made me realize look if he
can do it I'm glad I did it because this
dude was probably sitting in a dungeon
somewhere you know car you know Carter
eyes in a plastic elbow you know we're
putting some you know putting some moles
on an ankle and he left that to come
here just to see some old classmates I
mean can you imagine that just being up
all night just just hammering out a
mahogany knee
you know just chipping chipping a
clavicle out of a piece of oak can you
imagine that mm-hmm so I'm glad I didn't
know he did that and he's tall too this
guy's really tall so he probably you
know he has to bend down probably to
chip away at some of these things or
however they do it and this guy's making
prosthetics and so it made me think man
I'm just you know I'm I'm glad I came
they had a fella a new this guy was
recently homoerotic and he hadn't been
homoerotic when we saw him in high
school
so suddenly he's out there you know he
got that neck on a swivel lurkin bruh
you know what I'm saying he smell him
you know he smell a little bit of Old
Spice in the distance you know and it's
fun to watch it's fun to watch oh that
you know somebody be newly gay like oh
hope none of these uh hope none of these
former football high school football
players have too many cocktails at this
thing because they go and be suddenly
they gonna be they all somebody's gonna
be a wide receiver even if they play
defense because we got a new hitter out
in the game they had a new gentleman out
here and then you see all type of people
you know they had a girl in our class
who she'd lost a ton of weight and you
know you could just see how inspired she
felt and just and how inspired I was
inspired seeing her I was like wow you
know the commitment that that you know
the commitment it takes to change
because we just get cut we get used to
things we get comfortable in our ways so
the there was just a lot of it was just
interesting you know seeing people that
were more just more outgoing now you
know you see an old girl that you never
asked out and then there she is you know
there was a girl that I never asked out
when I was in school and I always I
think Etta I think for but I was just
too afraid you know she was just she was
so pretty and she was confident or she
was pretty to me you know she may not be
pretty to everybody that's subjective or
objective I don't know the difference
between those things but I saw it I just
you know just it took it takes you back
it took me back into that nervous body
that I was in for so long as a child
just that nervous I used to fix my hair
before I left the house when I was young
do what [ __ ] brahh dude if I put a comb
near my hair right now one of my
sideburns or my mom the back of my hair
this fleet some people call it a mullet
I called it the Lord's work but that if
I put if I put a comb near my hair one
of my sideburns would reach out and
choke it choke that [ __ ] comb out
does it come on yeah man so but there I
was I was back there and then you know
it was just nice cuz in it you know I
was talking her for a few minutes and
and it just took me back to my nervous
body you know back when I I you know I
wish I always had my I remember
sometimes I'll be so nervous as a kid I
would have my hands just on my pants
like this like folded up like little
penguin arms as even if they weren't in
my pocket sometimes I would put my hands
just
my hips and I think they were in my
pockets and they weren't and people
would be like do what the [ __ ] breath
are you like just feeling your thighs
dude out here in the hallway you better
G up you better G up do you need a Red
Bull baby boy you better G up yeah and
so that's one thing I'm glad I'm glad
that I went back cuz I don't have that
regret you know I was you know I was sad
that I had to miss the comedy show but I
don't have the regret of of not
participating really I just didn't want
to not be a participant you know I
didn't want to not honor that time in my
life and some people couldn't they have
children and they have you know some
people might have died you know and they
hug they might have been there you don't
know how many ghosts was there you know
I'm saying they don't do a uh they don't
you know they it's not like they had a
seance err in the room or somebody that
can operate a crystal ball decently to
tell us how many you know how many real
G's ghosts were in the building so they
might have a couple spirits out there
but it's just all of a sudden you know a
just reminded me of of all these moments
of all these moments and just being
young and I remember getting so high one
time driving to school and just hit you
know hit some girls car with my car and
I got out of the car and I didn't even
know what it happened
I thought our cars I was like - I
remember asking her for our cars had
magnets in them and maybe that's why
they hit each other and she was like
what [ __ ] she's like you hit me I was
like I think these cars have magnets in
them dude and I thought they did I was
this I was high as hell did I was an
idiot but when your whole body's just
running on testosterone you're young
when you coffee and you just have just
some testosterone will fly out of your
face but our old principal showed up
this dude I thought his name was coach
Pat and his name was coach Rob I didn't
I never saw him you know I saw the
disciplinarian you know I knew that lady
she look like kind of like a little bit
like Big Bird a little bit but a little
bit hotter
ever thought Big Bird was attractive but
you know I saw coat you know our
principal that was cool and I do on the
low heat on the DL he told me and I
shouldn't be you know maybe I'm sharing
that but whatever he was like you know I
thought uh he said I thought so and so
it was a real [ __ ] back in the day and
dude just to hear your old principal say
that about it somebody else that worked
in the school system amen that made it
work that right there but yeah it was
just nice to see other people and and
there were other people that showed up
you know one girl only went to our
school for two years and she showed up
and then um you know another young lady
that's a schoolteacher now some guy that
just you know his wife just got locked
up and so he's out there free you know
and he got his hair he kind of got his
hair kind of styled up and he's g'd out
and he you know bought himself some new
Giorgio Armani Cologne and he's out
there stunting and a Mustang now but you
just see people's lives just turning
people hitting different chapters and so
yeah that's why I'm glad I went because
because at the end of the night I was
talking to a couple of gals and a couple
of fellas and I realized that you know
if I if if we don't show up then there
is no reunion that's what makes it a
reunion is people showing up because yet
everything in everything we want to put
on or do or be a part of yeah it could
not be [ __ ] unless we show up and
participate so that's when I realized
look you know all this thing is is us
showing up and that's what I'm realizing
a lot of things are it's just you got to
show up you got to show up and then you
see what happened and I end up having a
good time you know I'd stepped out of my
paleo diet because I was in Louisiana
and dude it broke something I'll crawl
in your mouth in Louisiana and at first
you'll be scared because you're like
what in the [ __ ] is in on the health but
then you'll chew it up and be like
goddamn that was good that was good
and so that's just you know you if
you're they don't have diets in
Louisiana really I mean except for try
not to get murdered that's like the
number one diet in New Orleans area in
Baton Rouge but it was a joy man it was
a joy just seeing people and you know
just seeing what everybody's going
through and seeing that do to me
prosthetics you know that shit's amazing
to me imagine having that extra leg
imagine having that detachable leg
you're trying to go out you know maybe
you're going fishing and you want to
keep some of your nice legs dry so you
put on some you know some linoleum you
know baby boys you know you said you you
know you screw in a couple of are a
couple of are not mahogany but a couple
of velour hips or something you know you
should you screw in some some velour
calves and ankles imagine that or you
want you know you're just gonna relax in
the other room and read so you put on
some [ __ ] goose skin Famers imagine
that that's the future that's the future
you know a lot of things are going to
change in the future that people haven't
started to think about and one of those
things is you're gonna have pants in the
future they're gonna have pants that if
you want you want to go run put on your
jogging pants and old jogging pants the
ones we have right now they don't do
[ __ ] you still got a jog they're just
really just pants false advertising but
in the future in LA fedora
you're gonna put on some jogging pants
that are gonna and you're gonna press a
button and those [ __ ] are gonna go
about four miles so ya better be ready
dude can you imagine how great that's
gonna be when you have pants and you
press that button and then you're off
you could you could be tight you could
text while you're in them you could do
what you want you just got a wave every
now and then when you pass the neighbors
or you got a whistle every now and then
when you pass somebody that's sexy and
it could be a man or a woman am I
talking about
just cat calling women people get upset
about that but those new you can have
karate
kick pants somebody's talking [ __ ] you
going out to the club whatever put on
them bad cats put on them strike force
jeans it's gonna say strike force down
the side and first you out there doing a
little bit of kappa we're in this
shuttle you hit somebody with that
electric foot and that's the type of
stuff we're gonna have in the future
we're gonna have types of clothes that
will activate to do what we want to do
you know you're gonna have one of them
hugs sweaters be like oh [ __ ] Aunt Mary
wore her hug sweater she's gonna be and
last year and last year at malfunctioned
so she was just you know she wouldn't
let go with a dog for an hour because
you won't have that hug sweater just you
just start hugging people plan G mm-hmm
I love you I love you I love you and
that thing shorts out a little bit and
next thing you know you get electrocuted
so anything's possible is what I'm
saying
but yeah I'm glad that I went home man
this podcast is starting to catch up
look I was in I went to meet my sister
my sister has two beautiful children and
um and I love them and they're so you
know they love me they think I'm funny
and that makes me feel good you know
they think I'm like a goofy guy and
that's fun because I get to be that
around them and so we went to pizza and
they live out in the country I mean
it'll by the interstate like it's one of
those houses where when you're driving
by on the interstate you're like dang
they shouldn't live that close to the
interstate and they got a bass they have
a fish tank with a bass in it and it
can't the bass can't even turn around
the bass is too big the tank is just
about the size of like a shoebox so the
bass they have to feed it just at the
front of the tank because the bass can't
even that's just a one-way fish and and
we went and I went and met my sister and
my mom was gonna meet us and then my mom
couldn't come and my feelings got a
little bit hurt you know because I guess
you know we're not mom Alicia but my
mother has been I've always felt and I
just realized this when I was there we
were gonna meet up with our mom and then
she couldn't come she had to work and my
mom does delivery you know she delivers
you know magazines and newspapers and
that and she had she got a delivery
called and she had to do it and I
respect that because she has to work you
know she has to survive and and she got
her husband mr. charlie and he gots
Alzheimer's and that's when your brain
goes to heaven but you still down here
[ __ ] milling around and so he got you
know he's over you know he's he's
sitting in the passenger seat so she has
to go everywhere she goes so my mom's
out there in that van in that windowless
van you know just dropping off you know
magazines and you know special specialty
booklets and mr. Charlie's just out
there just you know he's out there
Apollo 13 and bruh he's out there just
working freelance in his own skin but
she couldn't come in and it made me
think you know what in it first it hurt
my feelings and I was I was kind of mad
at her but then I was trying to think
well why am i mad and I guess a lot of
times for me my mother has always had to
work you know the hardest-working man
I've ever known was my mother and so you
know I guess I was just mad because she
wasn't available you know it's always
like my whole life every time I've tried
to like do something special for my mom
or because I was trying to surprise her
that's the thing I was trying to
surprise her by meeting up with my
nieces and going to dinner with her and
and so and she couldn't come you know
and I think that's and it just kind of I
don't know man it's kind of lame I guess
I'm not lame but you know it just most
of my life my mother hasn't been
available you know she's always been
busy she's always had something to do
she's always felt a lot of pressure to
and I don't know where it comes from you
know because I wasn't there when my
mother was a child but she's always just
been so busy that it's hard to get her
out of whatever her busy is it's hard
it's hard to get a moment with her where
I feel like we just can be
okay around each other and okay together
and so this should kind of hurt my
feelings but I had to just swallow but I
had to shut up and just say nothing
because what am I gonna you know you
know I just have to be grateful that my
mother has work and that she is able to
work because she likes to work and
that's that's all I can do you know at
this point it's not words sometimes
saying the things it's just you know
I'll just tell her I love her and we go
on and that's it you know at some points
like if I'm Bristow if I if I'm just
playing old songs from back you know
complaint you know and just it is what
it is what am I gonna do you know I can
let her know oh you know I really wish
we could spend more time together those
are things that I can do but but to sit
there and hold it against her and then
my mother still has to work but now she
has to feel bad you know that's just
what I didn't want to do try to swallow
my own ego and stuff and and just kind
of get through that moment but a lot of
sacrifice is out there you know a lot of
people sacrificed for our country a lot
of women and men of sacrifice for their
family their time their dreams you know
sometimes I don't think we you know I
don't ever think about that like I
wonder what my mom's dreams were when
she was little you know wonderful in the
future we'll be able to travel back into
our into our like our and through our
genetics into our parents and our
grandparents thoughts
wouldn't it be fascinating like you're
not traveling through time because that
seems I don't think it seems far-fetched
you know because we have those moments
of you know man I feel like I've been
here before
but but to travel through our genetics
to me seems more plausible you know
because that's a real thing that's
living inside of us and I definitely
feel like our bodies have memory I feel
sometimes like there's a brain in my
heart you know because I'll get feelings
in my heart that are they're more than
just a an ache or a want
it's a sometimes in my heart I can feel
like I almost uh like it's like my heart
is like curious or like my heart is
thinking and that may sound crazy and
that's just me explaining some of the
feelings that I have but I think we're
gonna really start to find that that our
bodies have so much more ability to mem
to memorize and to think than we realize
and not just our brains because I even
I'll say this man I've been on this
Paleo diet you know and Paleo diet is
it's basically you're a scavenger you're
a hunter I mean you can [ __ ] kill
somebody in a parking lot you know in
the afternoon you won't think twice
about it and that's what's you know it's
really interesting about the diet is
it's you know apparently you can have
fruits you can have lean meat and you
can murder those are all okay on this
diet and eggs and pure maple syrup for a
sweetener but I start to I start to
realize like now I start to notice that
I eat only because I need to eat and my
body doesn't feel as addicted to
whatever like chemicals and extra
preservatives and things like that that
are in a lot of processed foods I'm not
saying I'll always be on this diet I'm
not preaching at you I'm just telling
you [ __ ] out notice so I noticed that
like so my my stomach doesn't get real
hungry I have a thought that I instead
of a memory that comes from my stomach
my stomach like being like oh I need to
eat I need to eat I'm starving
instead I get a thought in my head that
says hey it's probably time to eat you
know you should eat in the next couple
hours it's more of a survival it's more
instinctual but I'm noticing that before
I would get this almost like this
addiction or this this this craving like
this memory that my stomach had of of
whatever chemicals I was putting into it
or whatever preservatives and stuff are
going into my stomach and I don't get
that now and so that's another thing
that's making me think oh well maybe our
stomachs do have and our other organs do
have a lot more memory than we think
they do
now that's imagine that if you could if
you who knows who knows what the future
has you know it sure as hell they're
gonna have a hat that can comb your hair
damn you see [ __ ] Rhonda put on that
top hat and she's [ __ ] permed up an
hour later gotta get me one of those
I want the Hat I want that boat so those
are some things that have just been
going through my head you know this is
this it is what it is it is what it is
but yeah I had a good time man I spent
some time with one of my friends we went
around you know we got dressed up and we
went over to that highschool reunion we
made the most of it and we didn't have a
DJ at that thing because it you know not
enough people came we couldn't afford
that deejay but somebody started singing
a little bit in the evening and and what
else it was just a nice flight I saw our
senior hall on the way back and so that
was pretty cool because our senior was
the first and the only late-night talk
show host who had put me on his show to
do stand-up comedy and this is about
four years ago and all the other ones
passed on my tape and and he put me on
and it made me wonder also what why are
all the late-night talk show hosts white
you know I'm not saying there's anything
wrong with him being white or not being
white but it seems a little you know
like I wouldn't mind somebody that's
mixed at the least you know you guys
can't get at least a a white person that
was raised by black parents you know
let's get what about a sweet a beautiful
Asian or how about a sweet Latino that
nighttime vile oh you noticed wouldn't
Monty know Lou you know they really got
it cornered out there with these whites
on these late night shows but then it
sometimes I just want to see diversity
and things just to make it more
interesting you know a lot I don't know
you know I agree sometimes with the
force diversity thing I don't like it
because I don't know if it if it if it
imitates life sometimes but it's just
like the NBA the NBA gets really boring
to me because it's all tall black men
it's just because here's why cuz when I
watch it I don't feel like everybody has
a chance to be in it so for me I lose
that allure you know it's like oh I
can't even I'd have no shot to be in
this what about that fifty year old you
know Vietnamese gunner out on the
three-point line you know you want to
see that dude whatever his name is
little Starbuck or whatever you know you
want to see Starbuck out there at that
three-point stripe wearing pants dude
and if you don't know that a lot of
Vietnamese men play basketball in pants
then you don't know get out there and
meet some men because they got men out
there some beautiful vietze out there
just pantalones for Shoney's boy and
just gunning from deep you'll see a guy
shoot from 70 feet with a volleyball
bang bang that's a 9 pointer baby so I'm
just singing that I would like to see
that you know you you telling me you
can't find uh you know a Kobe Bryant a
little a JIT little Japanese guy or a
lot to a Mexican guy do come on here not
as well you know I want to see it
because I want to see it then that seems
like more of a team that that's more of
a sport that exemplifies everything you
know that's why I want to see a golfer
in there in a wheelchair and put him in
the [ __ ] you don't want to see him
set a break on a really steep hill and
[ __ ] hit that uh that's 6-iron 100
and 140 yards I want to see people set
it off you know ensure you get these
[ __ ] gets risky on that hillside if it's
windy or if it's slope you know if
there's aa small avalanche but whatever
you got to get a little bit extra
insurance on that guy cuz he's out there
but uh you know I wouldn't mind seeing
that or seeing somebody with no arms be
in the swim competition get in the pool
that's Sally right there and they call
him salamander and that doobie out there
just just face-first boy just sneaking
just
and just sneaking through that and I
want that's the vibe I wanna see that
viola I don't you know mix it all
together let's see who really wins this
[ __ ] that's all I don't want to see
sometimes I just want to see I don't
want force diversity but I want to see
things mixed but so that it just feels
like [ __ ] reality because you're
telling me this dude they got men out
there seven feet tall and the goal is
only ten feet that's not hard to play on
dude
that's easy and matter of fact that's
easy
put that thing at 13 feet let's see
who's a real Moonwalker Din sorry I
don't mean to go off but I just get
queued in and I'm gonna get fired up but
thank you guys for being here on this
past weekend you know what's crazy we're
coming up on a hundred episodes uh in
that wild a hundred episodes and I
remember we started this thing on
December I want to say December 19th
December 18th I don't even know honestly
I said look but man I want to thank you
guys so much for being here with us so
far and things are growing so fast and
we have so much neat stuff happening and
I really really want to thank you guys I
want to say we have some some great
dates coming up one of those is going to
be in West Siloam Springs and that's
coming up at Cherokee Casino West Siloam
Springs Oklahoma now if you know
somebody in that area that's a single
mother who doesn't usually get out that
we could accommodate their evening you
know take care of them get them and a
friend out to a show and take care of
their babysitter let us know and you can
hit me up on Theo von comm under contact
on there or Theo van comm slash podcast
there's way to get in touch right there
and and you may not know anybody and
that's fine
and now wouldn't say anything to them
yet or anything like that but if you do
know somebody in that area Cherokee
Casino I'll be there June 9th and that's
in two weeks
West Siloam Springs Oklahoma hit us up
on the hotline or arm through the
websites and let us know and we're gonna
see if we can't do something nice out
there for a single mom and get this
little program
: june 15th through 16th Yuk Yuk's
Calgary Alberta Canada June 23rd temblor
Brewing Company Bakersfield we just
added a second show June 29th I'll be at
the Paramount Theatre in Stark County
Illinois and that's in the town of
Wyoming Illinois and that's a fundraiser
July 6th through the 8th at levity live
in Oxnard California July 20th through
the 22nd charlie good nights Raleigh
North Carolina a autist 16th through
18th Laugh Factory Chicago September
14th and 15th that's zany's in Nashville
Tennessee
October 18th through the 20th that
skyline comedy club Appleton Wisconsin
November 1 through 3 helium comedy club
Buffalo New York we're also adding dates
I believe for Toronto and who knows
where else oh right the hot line is
always is nine eight five six six four
nine five zero three let's get into a
few calls here here we go this is John
it's Theo but let's hear more John thank
you for calling
John Amelia Tom and two cats boy it
sound like a sound like a low-key
swingers meet up over there in
Connecticut or something less sound like
something rich people doing on words
Jersey is New Jersey and right next to
us is a town called chrome Dell and just
the other day a story broke where
there's a Holmdel high school
superintendent was found out to be
sitting on the track of their school
okay so you're talking about defecation
athletics homeward everyday they felt
that they were like the generators had
to cleaning up every single day and
they're like who is doing this and they
eventually caught him on surveillance
and it was the superintendent of the
school Amelia who is said her name
before pointed out that that just was
something that we need to tough at the
Avon well I appreciate you calling this
in John a million Tom well yeah I mean
the guy you said he was doing it daily
I'm not surprised by that because people
defecate daily I don't trust anybody
that doesn't know defecate
six times a week if you out there
defecating five times then that's pretty
crazy because that means you're just
running around us you know you're just
hiding you know defecation in your body
you know you just out there you just
mewling your own Dookie around you're
just a Dookie mule for yourself get it
out of your body
you got to do six times a week i guy I
got an old friend you know and I had to
let him go because he only [ __ ] twice a
week huh
that means every time I'm talking to you
you just you got like it you know you
got probably about 60 grams of just
defecation just hanging out your body
for no reason because you're too lazy to
let it out it's like somebody that
doesn't take their dog for a walk you
know I'm saying you got to take those
body dogs for walk and just walk them
right into that tank into that bathroom
tank that's wallet so just if somebody
ain't [ __ ] six times a week then
then are we friends uh ah I don't know I
really don't know but look this man is
Superintendent of Schools obviously he
was probably fed up with his job and he
just couldn't find a way to do it and
also once you start doing stuff outdoors
and you start you know you get out more
outdoors you that stuff gets addictive
you know you go for one run you want to
go for another run you know and if you
[ __ ] probably once on a track then you
know I could see I could see probably
doing it you know it getting probably
addictive I mean addiction is crazy
people are addicted everything there's
people addicted there are meetings for
in in Los Angeles for people who are
addicted to chapstick there's but
there's meetings for people who were
addicted to not blinking there's people
that don't want to blink think about
that just dry eyed as [ __ ] just trying
to hold them open all day until they go
to bed at night that's the dark arts and
there's people like that so I'm not
surprised a superintendent in the
schools he probably got some ego he
thinks he's this big bad dude he's
running the show and next thing you know
he's out there defecating and also then
maybe he didn't like his janitorial
stuff maybe he thought the staff was
slacking maybe this is his last term and
he didn't give a damn
maybe he's trying to get a new mascot
you know the you know the bomb the brown
bombers and this dude's just trying to
you know lay out you know lay a track in
people's heads first before he you know
lobs that name that name out there but I
appreciate you guys calling it I don't
trust anybody I don't [ __ ] six times a
week
and I don't think it you should but I'm
not here to tell you what you should or
shouldn't do but I'll tell you what I'm
doing and I'm not people I'm not
trusting people that that don't go
number two when they have to do it what
are you doing
your body is saying hey I'm all good
here and you're saying nah you keep that
in your mouth come on cam mm who are we
are we rhythm or are we dancers let's
take another call here thank you guys
for calling in from Great Neck New
Jersey or Colts Neck or whatever it was
some someplace out there in the
beautiful New Jersey real people out
there now respect it homeward
calling may be further advice thanks for
calling I don't have advice for you but
I'll definitely I'll give you some segi
a suggestion that I have and I don't say
that you know it's kind of a reprimand
you in any way but but for me I don't
hear advice that well but I hear
suggestions because you know advice if I
get advice from people it makes me think
for me it makes me think that that
person thinks they know more than me and
for some reason you know I'm a you know
I'm I've always you know or when I was
young I had to always do things for
myself and so I don't like to take other
people's advice because you know there's
something inside of me that's like I'm
not listening to that person you know I
I've always taken care of myself I know
I know I know what's best for me but a
suggestion I'm able to hear those a
little bit more and so I'm gonna offer a
suggestion though and I do appreciate
you calling man it's brave II to call
and hit the hotline nine eight five six
six four nine five zero three thanks for
calling let's hear more
I am currently living my parents ok-hee
Colonel doing with the rents dude and
that's okay you know what I don't like
about living with the parents though is
uh you got to smell other people's
bodies you know your parents it's cool
when you're young because they're
smelling you you're the one making the
smells around the house but when you get
a little older and you still at your
folks house then you start smelling them
and it's like oh oh why just graduated I
have a full-time job starting a career
well good and my girlfriend wants to
move in with me mm-hmm and that's it you
know that's that New Age lady a lot of
these New Age ladies yeah when I was
young you would put a ladder on your
lady's door and sneak up there at night
and then right when you got into her
bedroom her dad will pop up from behind
the bed and punch you in the [ __ ]
neck but now you got these ladies they
trying to sneak in you know you don't
even know yeah I unpacked one of my bags
at home the other day had two ladies in
it like who were these ladies but thanks
for calling homeward and I got a little
bit student debt and mine's a little bit
tight but I can do it and it's feasible
and so I'm just wondering if you know
this is the right decision we're here to
tell some comments are about it I'm 24
what having it's time to you know yeah
my parents house will move on but scary
you know
I already made a decision that I think
I'm gonna do it but so I was wondering
if she had any advice you know thoughts
comments for me there you go and I
appreciate you calling and I'll say this
about moving out you know it sounds like
you're a responsible guy and I I applaud
that I mean a lot of 24 year olds they
don't even know a lot of these kids out
there sitting in their front yard on LSD
you know just trying to figure out if
they're tozer
in the best order naturally you know by
height or whatever classification
whatever but you some you know you
something you know you label off a
couple things you have a job you just
graduated you're working full-time
you're manager you're juggling a
relationship you know your understanding
you're moving out
and that there's some responsibilities
added there man it sounds like you're
doing okay I think you're gonna be fine
and I'll say this man I don't know your
parents but I'm proud of you did I look
I have zero kids but I would be so proud
of humor my kid I mean you sound like uh
you sound like somebody that cares about
yourself that's taken a lot of
responsibility and so and your parents
will always be there if things get tough
and you have to go back that's that's
not taking a loss that's taking a learn
you know through any experience even if
it doesn't work out for you you can take
an L and that L can be a learning you
know and I actually that's our charter
sponsor is gray block pizza and the man
that runs that started that company is
this gentleman Thomas and he taught me
about that and it's and it's helped me
it's helped me when I feel like damn I
lost that [ __ ] but now I learned it and
next time I'll do it differently yeah I
mean look you're gonna have some freedom
though you're gonna have some freedom
you know your parents will probably look
at you a little different you'll start
to you know get some different airs you
and some new ideas will come into your
head when you're in a space because when
you put yourself in uncomfortable find
ways and and the world will find ways a
lot of times to to even things out for
you to get you back into comfort and so
you don't know the world might give you
a new opportunity your brain might look
at things a little bit differently and
find a way to make something in your
life that was tougher before make it
easier for you now you know it's amazing
what what pressure can do to your to
your brain what positive pressure and I
consider moving out you're not consider
that putting like a positive pressure on
yourself you know because it's you know
it's amazing so what what what is inside
of us would our higher powers are
whatever put inside of us do we're we're
remarkable creatures I mean we're all so
straight Muppets you know somebody right
now is listening to this and just walked
into traffic and you know what
we appreciate them taking one for the
team but it's uh we're remarkable
creatures in the sense that when we put
ourselves into uncomfort when we put
ourselves in a change that that we will
a lot of times rise to the occasion or
you sound like somebody that might you
suddenly really sound like somebody that
might so I say give it a shot and you
can always take a learn you can always
take a step back yet I'm sure your
parents would love to have you back in
the house I don't know you know maybe to
get in tired of splitting that pizza you
know maybe I'll all get tired of
smelling each other but you know I'm
sure you sound like a nice a good son
and I bet that they're super proud of
you and I'm sure that they would be
happy to have you now if you got to go
back look I moved in and out of the
house it's nine times with a family that
wasn't even mine
so so it's okay if you have to and with
the girlfriend situation now having her
move in with you immediately when you
get out I mean maybe that's what you're
maybe you're headed for marriage and
that's where you're looking for you know
maybe I might take a set you know take a
secondary beat there and just kind of
feel that out a little bit more you know
even if it's just a couple weeks by
yourself but if she's already living
with you and you guys are going together
then go do it
you know you can always take a step
sideways and that's just a step to uh to
think about things or you can always
take a learn brother let's say let's get
onward and take another question on word
what's up Brian from Los Angeles thanks
for calling in like a recommendation or
just kind of like my thing okay you had
that one homeboy or Greyhound yeah we
had the Greyhound driver um and I you
know I hate to say I can t remember his
name at the moment he stood us up and
then he came in didn't really say much
but he was he was nice but but yeah he
might have been a plant he might have
been a government plant
onward strike in his mind about how
great out work but what's wrong with ten
people on your pocket whether they're
tannic doctors said you know anything
like that you know just get there inside
they're experienced things that they see
you're on armies because I'm my own
mechanic an army I just want to like how
that's you you know because there's
there's a couple great story too you
know I mean out there I appreciate that
call Brian yeah well look I'm trying not
to close off my mind to any type of
guest you know I'm still learning a lot
about being with guess you know some
guests they it's almost like a script
with them they just go into it and start
communicating and you it's hard to even
get questions in you know I want to get
people in that can converse eight more
with I want to have people in that I
have some sort of a purpose to talk to
and and you're right that should be
anyone and it is you know but it's also
like you get a guy you know you think
you get a guy who's gonna be I have a
lot to share and a lot of insight like
the Greyhound driver and he didn't have
much and that's what we have to do
another greyhound episode coming up when
we're looking for a better driver if you
know anybody that has worked for
greyhound
who lives in the Los Angeles area will
pay them for their time but we'd love to
have them come on so you can hit the
hotline and let us know that but look I
want to have all types of regular people
you know anybody people that can hold
their breath midwives con artists you
know people that work maybe we're
accused of you know you know dirty
crimes repeats or whatever but didn't do
it didn't do it you know murderers who
share who did their time I'm interested
in anybody and if there's somebody out
there that you think has a you have a
really special guest he thinks great hit
the hotline let us know make sure they
live in Los Angeles the only thing we
don't have that kind of a budget but we
will you know we want to have
interesting people and we're going to
continue to but I preach
you saying that Brian yeah everybody has
a story but we also have to make sure
that people can you know have some
ability to share that story so that we
can just because we owe that to our
listeners and we owe that to ourselves
and we also don't want to get somebody
in here make them feel uncomfortable you
know if you get some cats like to get
their hair cut I like to get their hair
styled you know sometime you'll see a
cat with a little bit of a jheri curl
around its [ __ ] but sometimes you get
a cat and you break out that hair
coloring kit and they jump out the seat
and that's that's not the kind of cat we
want we want the cat that's ready to
have a little bit of s curl or a finger
wave around that around that on who's
that anus let's hear more let's take
another call here and look we'll go in
and out of the calls it's not like once
we get into the calls we go do two calls
it's this is what it is
this is Memorial Day weekend you know
people died so we could do this however
we want you know people can you believe
that people died people died man some of
you listeners right now you lost
something you lost a family member you
know were you looking at some of y'all
you know scratching a ghost leg or leg
roast you know trying to scratch your
armor now you don't even have an arm
because you left your arm in another
country defending this one I mean I'm
grateful I'm grateful for this country
we're gonna do great things I'm not
sitting here listening to the news
telling me this and that and fighting
about who should be here and who
shouldn't be here onward baby I'm moving
onward if somebody needs help and I'm
there I'm gonna help but I'm not falling
into this trap of this [ __ ]
constantly baiting me into thinking that
America is bad things are going ok and I
think actually things are going better
than okay I think we're well I think
we're in a better place now than when
we're 10 years ago I hope we are I think
we have a lot of the same problems but I
think we need to start thinking more
about solution and just quit complaining
about everything what is the solution
how what do we find it and I fall into a
2-man we all do
maybe we all don't I do you know I get
caught up in the complaints
if you need me I'll be in the complaint
section trying on a a couple of combines
you know how does this uh you know this
uh you know how does this this this
complain dress fit me just trying on
complaints oh how does this a shoulda
woulda coulda wife beater fit me is it
too tight let's take another call here
we go Eric calling us from California
hey Eric from California California I'm
in your state as well right now thank
you for calling brother homeward
Northern California you listen to your
podcast just heard the just one last tax
week where you were on Joe Rogan's and
yeah and thank you for listening to that
too man
Joe sent me a text on Friday saying how
he got in such a nice response and then
I got such a great response I can't even
tell you a no joke I think I got maybe
three four thousand deems just about the
podcast but what I can't it would take
me two months to respond all of them and
I've tried on some it's just
overwhelming you know it's overwhelming
even just be on your phone that much but
thank you guys so much for people have
reached out and and just said that they
enjoyed listening to that I enjoyed it I
talked about it on my last episode on
word at six for box coloring right there
boy but uh I heard you come back and
cons playing like thinking that whole
universe like if you would have met
yourself would you be like prouder you
know how would you feel and I've been
kind of thinking about that myself and
uh man you know as silly as this might
sound that's kind of what I needed to
hear to to just put the [ __ ] bottle
down then mmm I figured if I met myself
I wouldn't like who I was meeting I was
about to pour myself a drink and I just
decided not to you know because I wasn't
like that
but uh made me think a little tasty oh
thank you thanks for the call yeah well
Joe made me think and we just out here
playing telephone making people think
but I'm glad I could help you think a
little bit yeah sometimes I've been to
those moments like what is this next one
gonna do for me or what is this next you
know page a pornography or what is this
next you know mean text or what is this
next you know hit off this joint or what
is this next gram a cocaine or what is
this next you know parking in my
neighbor's yard or what is this win it
what is it gonna do for me
you know I get to the I've been to those
moments
we're just run like you know things work
for you even if they're things that
aren't good for you they work for you
until they don't work anymore and then
for me I have to ask myself well why why
why of what am i using this for in the
first place is it a thought that I don't
want to think about is it a uncomfort
like if I don't pour that beer then I
just sit there uncomfortable what is
that uncomfort what is it because that's
what my real that's what that's my dark
artist whatever that uncomfort is that
makes me get to the point where whatever
I'm using to check out of myself
whatever I'm using to escape doesn't
work then that's when that's when it's
like okay I need a look I need to I need
to look at this a little more what am i
what am i I don't feel good about what
I'm thinking about what I'm doing I
don't feel good about what somebody's
doing in me I don't feel I feel less
saying I feel shameful what do I you
know what do I feel and that's what you
know that for me that kind of stuff is
that's where that all that goes it's
starting then that self exploration and
I'm just out here speed lankan into
myself trying to
huh it's a Duras man this can be a dirty
road we live on but but they got a lot
of tables of water set up as we're
jogging it don't they and we get those
hitters from different people you know
and I listen to Joe and you listen here
and and then somebody else listens to
this now because you called in and we're
all we're all thinking you know we're
all thinking Oh
onward let's hear more things for
calling Eric and also if you [ __ ]
party and do [ __ ] you're doing it
good keep on keep on here we go hey
how's it going Theo von and to anyone
listening I was just calling in to give
my best worst weekend okay and this will
be the last this would be the last
submission for this week
each week we have we can call in and let
us know what your best our worst weekend
how your weekend was if it was the best
or worst make sure it's it's one or the
other
don't call them with some mediocre
weekend you know you ain't gone Thor
went over to the lake or something and
you know in a dejar of all lives
together cuz you know why don't give a
fake I want to hear something wild you
know somebody swallowed a damn barbell
or something it needs to be interesting
but thank you for calling you can hit
those you can own those stories you can
leave them at nine eighty five six six
four nine five zero three on the hotline
once a month we'll take the best or
worst weekend whichever one it was
whoever that was in cinema this past
weekend package it's got um it's got
these hostas Correctional Center blue
t-shirts and we'll send you one of those
and a couple of other items on word on
my way home from work and I I bike to
and from work I'm about seven miles away
it's about nine o'clock I'm heading down
the dark so I'm flying maybe thirty
miles an hour oke thirty miles an hour
on a bicycle
woo it sound like you trying to go catch
a bag of dope because usually if you see
an adult male doing 30 mph --is on a
bicicleta he's after that how can you
feel me he dude he's on that uh toward a
dust
he said he's hitting them French Alps to
go get them Whitecaps you feel man and
I'm going and before I know what I'm
just you know I saw the green and I'm
going for and I see someone's making a
left turn and I'm just I see it coming I
had about maybe one second before I get
this is uh yeah I just let out one big
just what do you think it was a fart
[ __ ] oh just a [ __ ] okay and Chris I
smacked the side of his car and of
course I go you know fly up the Loom you
know dinner goes everywhere I'm on the
top of his car a little bit and then I
kind of push and roll off and land in
the road
cops end up showing up because he goes
ahead and called them told me I didn't
have a light on my bicycle whatever in
there but it's okay cops show up they
you know they just talk some
informations whatever it's good I'm
walking it's all good police officer he
did a bit thing you know he fixed my
bike right there and spasso shout out to
him and he be you know on him
okay so you had some help for an
officer's you hit a car with your bike
you didn't have a light on it man I
can't do it honestly I can't stand a lot
of times sometimes especially in Los
Angeles they try to force everything
into there's already so much traffic and
then they gotta you know by cyclists and
everybody got jugglers they got a lane
for unicyclists they got a lane for
people that are afraid to be outside
they got a lane for people with iditarod
animals they got a lane for people that
are afraid of the sunlight you know they
got a lane for complete [ __ ] so and
you know look in California some of this
stuff gets way it gets to be too much I
mean I don't know if you had a bike
helmet on or not honestly I hope you
didn't bro but not in a bad way for you
I can't trust an adult male that wears a
bike helmet sorry I you know oh the like
I'd rather my dad you know be jarred up
in the brain then hear him tell me a
story about when he got hit by a car and
had a helmet on I just can't because I
hit then I would picture him with a
helmet with shorts riding a bicycle and
then I would just you know picture him
hopefully this riding on out of my life
because I can't imagine that
as a man that my cheese SMO in me what
little I have I can't imagine I can't
imagine a man a father of that that is
not that's not for me you don't want
that Dad they guess you know maybe he
gets iced out by that by a TransAm or
something because I got hit by a TransAm
when I was young and you didn't have a
helmet on and he's a little different
but he's still my dad and there's no
pictures of him anywhere or proof that
he ever wore a bike helmet as an adult
male is that is that a crazy weekend you
look at stuff it sounds tough for you
dinner whenever we're you lost the
dinner I feel bad for you bruh I
appreciate you calling with that if you
have a good one or a bad one you can hit
the hotline oh all right let's take a
let's take another one here we go hey a
Matt from Nashville thank you for
calling I'll be coming there I believe
in September or onward kind of talk to
you about smoking cigarettes a little
bit because there's something that Ari
said a long time ago about when people
quit cigarettes they want to tell
everybody around them that they're
quitting cigarettes and everybody goes
all congratulations you know good for
you but it's kind of jacked up your
reward system because you get that that
final outcome of what you're looking for
that like oh I did it but you get it in
the beginning when you haven't really
done any more oh that's interesting Matt
I'm definitely guilty of that I'm
definitely yeah I'll have like two days
you know or go a few days where I won't
smoke or I won't do a certain thing or
and then if I tell people then it's over
well I never thought about it that the
reward system that I get that reward
because then I'm like excuse me then
they hear like oh congratulations and I
hear that I'm like oh great our people
are already excited I'm already doing
great and then then there's no gold
medal out there it's almost the same
thing in a way of like that everybody
gets a trophy for playing in the ball
game you know everybody gets the trophy
that says you're great at baseball
that's a trophy
you know one of my nephew's got that
trophy you're great at baseball
everybody got it what the hell what does
that even mean so and one of their kids
on their team was blind he's but you
know he can't see god bless him you know
he might be able to see later let's
don't feel too sorry for him because we
don't know what God has planned for him
you know I'm saying he might bust out
with those new [ __ ] sight sockets in
two years and he may be you know he may
uh you know he may go from just black to
64 colors I'm saying he may be just that
renegade with that ROYGBIV he may change
the game up so let's don't feel too
sorry for the young guy at this point
but he got one so now he got to [ __ ]
have his now his somebody got to read
that him you're great at baseball so
he's sitting there in his head thinking
I'm great at baseball but I can't even
[ __ ] to see so then what does he go
to do he turns into Evel Knievel makes
you know he think he could do anything
you know and he rides a motorized bike
or a motorized cart or something out in
the traffic
you know just sometimes we don't want to
lead people astray with some of these
ideas and we don't want to give him that
reward before there is a reason for it
and I'd do that I'm grateful you brought
that to my attention cuz I do that man
you know I want that and I don't know if
it's that I want the reward and so
that's why I tell people you know let's
hear more what do you have to what other
thoughts do you have Matt I'll be honest
with you man I've been it's been about
three weeks now I've been back Island
are you back on them you back on them
yeah oh they get you a cigarette
sometimes it seemed like they got a long
arm sticking out the bottom of them with
a strong hand on it and just when you
think you just out there just like trick
lung Mickey with them new clean hitters
and then they drag you right back in
more have an autumn heart again
and so I know how you feeling man I know
I know the struggle is [ __ ] real
addiction but but it's dumb as [ __ ]
doing you know that so
I do and you're right and you know what
I can feel is even I can feel my lungs
start to have a memory of a cigarette
and that's the thing that gets scary is
when you could fill your lungs like oh
oh you know it's almost like that like
they're like they're thinking I can feel
my lungs almost thinking about a
cigarette and that might sound crazy but
wouldn't be surprised if I am thanks for
calling up Matt yeah maybe I should
watch out with that reward system but
you know just giving myself the you're
great at baseball when I've only been
you know barely swinging a bat for two
days
oh let's crack anymore I just finished
walking that a tinfoil hat podcast we
were there with them any problem that's
a one point man it was so funny you look
like you look like me my first calculus
class when the picture tells me yeah
calculus you ever have time in the fifth
grade when you when they taught you this
was the same thing and it just blew my
mind that they wanted me to remember all
that stuff after years and years it was
so funny man well thanks for calling in
about that yeah I went on tinfoil hat
podcast we haven't seen his podcast it's
um you know they talk a lot about it's
with Eddie Bravo and Sam Tripoli two men
that are that I really admire that make
me laugh and and they man there but
there it's it was off the deep end I
didn't think it was that deep that some
people are out there talking about you
know just things that they see and
they're in the you know you know it was
everything in one it by the artist it
was like JFK you know Loch Ness monster
um booby traps booby traps um you know
we didn't land on the moon oh it was
just a tower seven tower 62 oh I
couldn't even function I thought I was
gonna end up on a list and I had to I
had to bow out you know I'm certainly
open to talking about some of those
things conspiracy theories flat earth
thinking about that but this was deep
this
is deep and and I didn't know that
people went that deep and that to me I
don't want to be in that depth I do not
want to be in that depth because I can't
handle it
I couldn't handle it it was too much at
once for me so I think I need a weight
in the law
I got to get in there easy I gotta take
it in slow and I got to get in there
slow that's the deep end for me
but thanks for calling in about that
about that tinfoil hat podcast and look
I was thinking about this about the
moon-landing here's one thing that
strikes me about the moon-landing for
one I've met Buzz Aldrin and I looked in
his eyes and he didn't look to me it
didn't look like he had been to the moon
and I'm not saying that you know
everybody got that special lunar glow in
their eye you know everybody's got that
galactic twinkle in one of their [ __ ]
face balls if they have been to the moon
but he didn't have it for me you know
someone you meet some money and it looks
like oh yeah it looks like they've been
to Canada or it looks like they've been
to Africa or they look you know
exhausted and they smell like popcorn
and it looks like they'd been to the
mall while looked at mr. B Aldrin and I
looked at him I was like mmm the look in
his eyes it didn't look like he had been
to the moon now that's just what I'm
saying also I was thinking about this
can you believe that which we sent man
mission of the moon and successfully did
it the first time what what nobody does
anything right the first time what are
the odds that we did it the first time
that's what gets me the first time we
tried it oh we did it really no I just
can't fathom that I can't fathom that
the first time we tried it we did it it
seemed like maybe the 60th time we get
it right because you're going through
all types of like the Van Horne belt or
whatever or the vein yeah I think it's a
Van Horne but there's so many things
you're doing out there no it's not the
Van Horne belt what is it
yeah the something I don't know [ __ ] but
it's something like they got that baby
belt out there
these little rocks are coming at you
meteoroids you know megasaurus or
whatever they got all of that [ __ ] out
there Milky Way galaxy galaxy everything
you know side-side-angle whatever
everything's out there attacking you we
got it we landed the first time that's
the part that's for me that I don't know
did I try to drive to Jacksonville one
time got on the wrong road the first
time I try to Jack drive to Jacksonville
okay and and ended up in about 80 miles
north of Tallahassee so just saying and
I'm not incompetent
I'm decently competent I'm probably said
probably 80% competent so you telling me
we got to the moon first time we try
land it got out people are dancing and
stuff like that doubt skis okay I'm I
trying to go full polish on you but
doubt skis let's take another call here
that came in here we go
here we go Joe hey Theo this is Joe in
Minnesota hey I just want to touch base
with you on comments about the school
shootings and ar-fifteens and thanks for
calling Joe from Minnesota I'm looking
for a spot to do a couple shows on a
Saturday night in Minnesota if you know
of one that seats about you know 150 to
200 let me know trying to get that done
here in the next couple of weeks and and
just put it on the on the schedule for a
little bit later in the year you can
just drop me a DM I look I already know
the regular comedy clubs already know
but most of them they want you there for
a full weekend I'm already there for a
Friday night doing something like Gary
Vaynerchuk performance thing but I want
to do my own show there so just hit the
hotline or send me a DM but on word if
they're to blame or they should be
banned or let me start you over judge so
I can pay more attention please thanks
well this is Joe in Minnesota hey I just
want to touch base with you on your
comments about the school shootings and
they are 15s and yep thank you for
calling in about that more if they're to
blame or they should be banned or
whatnot I think the main reason we get
these shooting
is because they're on the news and we
show the kids face and we give their
name and their whole background we gotta
we gotta knock that off right away
that's a great point we make you know we
don't make I don't not saying we make
heroes out of these people out of these
kids that do this but we certainly I
mean yeah we put their faces we put all
this information we put their you know
the videos that they you know if they
made a video before they did it and
before they harm themselves or or
committed suicide we that all that stuff
goes out and immediately without even
knowing the effects what that has
long-term and without even knowing you
know if that desensitizes other children
at a certain point but yeah you're in a
world and at a time where social media
and digital or claim and having a
digital persona is is everything or not
everything but it's a lot of things
especially I'm assuming like in high
school you know a lot of these kids you
know younger people live on their
tablets I mean it my age alone we're
already infected enough by it but you
know I'm sure that they just see
themselves oh well digitally I'll just
be this villain and that'll be my role
and I'll be on the news and I'll be and
they'll all be talking about me and
somebody that feels so lonely suddenly
knows that they'll they'll be talked
about that there will be that they will
be looked at in all even if it's a
negative all but they're looked at in
all and for somebody that feels a net
probably never recognized to then have
the opportunity to be looked at in all I
mean that's that's it's you know yeah we
do that it's it's probably not helpful
and they do know in the I'm sure the new
the news does not care you wanted to
talk about an organ that I don't think
has off has a brain in its brain or in
its heart I think it's some of this news
networks I really do and you don't have
to agree with me on that and that's okay
and I could be wrong
I really could onward I think you'll see
them disappear or hopefully disappear
after that happens I know where you do
that we're a free country where people
can report on anything but I think that
has to change as far as the guns go you
know you can't I don't think you can
blame the guns at all we're a free
country where we can have a lot of
dangerous toys and do dangerous things
and you know you start taking those
things away you take the way the ar-15
you take away the car that can go 155
miles an hour so you take away the right
to go and let your store get a fifth of
Jack Daniel's and dress up your pitbull
like a minion and taking their sister's
birthday party you can do all kinds of
stupid [ __ ] and anyway that's just my -
appreciate your - there Joe from
Minnesota yeah yeah I know that's a lot
of people's fear once you start taking
away some things that other things what
else are we not going to be able to do
what else you not going to be able to do
and I had someone send me a DM the other
day about you know assault rifles and
that you know they're not the most most
people don't die from those in the
America and this sort of thing I get
that but I think is a general idea if it
helps people feel more comfortable even
though it might not actually solve
anything
I then does it then does it hurt to pass
laws that you need more time to get a
gun that you that they don't make guns
that you know how about what about some
hard rubber bullets
what about rubber cars people die in car
accidents every year where's the Fox is
the rubber cars you don't think I'll
drive a [ __ ] rubber re
huh you don't think I'll roll in a
convertible
dude rubber cars you'd have full-on
collisions you're furious on the
interstate at somebody have it out
rubber cars dude op imagine putting on a
rubber on your yanker and driving a
rubber car dude you could drive through
the dirtiest ladies or men in town and
be fine
you know I'm saying you could go
four-wheel-drive and somebody's deep in
and be a okay
rubber cars we need more rubber and I
know we have rubber because we have all
these extra trees dude I've been driving
I've been driving past trees before and
smelled rubber so what do you think that
is you telling me that I don't know
that's rubber man some of these trees
have rubber in them they're hiding it
and we got to get in there get in there
and we got to get him and look the
future is ours but I'm saying rubber
cars rubber shirts imagine giving
somebody a hug and bouncing out of it
real fast right back where you are
sometimes you if you hug somebody you
you know it takes almost a full second
to get back to your you know natural you
know position one imagine getting him
bouncing right back and you're ready for
conversation immediately that's what I'm
talking about more rubber stuff we can
do it guys I know we can but thank you
for calling in with your thoughts there
Joe let's take another call here here we
go this is a calls looking for
suggestions we'll get into some of those
also wanna let you know today's episode
is brought to you by the ridge wallet
the ridge is a minimalist front pocket
wallet
it's an exciting little little just that
you know that hard front carry baby bag
because sometimes you have that thing in
your hip and it looks like oh you know
that man has dysplasia you know that man
you know he probably grew up with wild
hips and he doesn't know how to use his
legs correctly or he walks sideways or
you know maybe one of his grandparents
was a spider but that's because really
it's not anything wrong with that person
it's just they have a rear wallet so now
what you can get is that is the ridge
wallet and I use one and at first I
wasn't sure about it
by day three I'm in Ridge me out you can
get in my Ridge and the ridge wallet
it's a front pocket carry and you get
rid of all the old things you were
carrying on your wall you don't need you
don't need that receipt dude nobody
honestly nobody gives a [ __ ] about it
not even you so you can get rid of all
those things the ridge wallet it's
simple it's minimal you put it in that
front pockets that front pocket carry go
to ridge while
calm / Theo and and get that hitter man
it's a beautiful deal you get 10% off
right there
now it's a higher it's a bit of a luxury
item so recognize that it's not for
everybody
and if you can't afford it don't feel
pressured but it is an item and now you
can go to Ridge wallet comm slash Theo
and get 10% off all right let's go into
another call here happy Memorial Day
everybody here we go what's up Mike we
got a lot of Jersey coming in thank you
for calling Mike people oh thanks for
calling yeah you sort of work on corn
soaring cotton Milo what else do we have
oh and bees we're farming bees but then
man
they were hoeing my rose a couple times
bruh I definitely been stung out
homeward a lot of hard work I mean from
what I've heard you've been working on a
farm and I love hearing about it I was
wondering what should he do when you
know more than your boss I give me [ __ ]
on that [ __ ] just some stuff doesn't
make sense and I've only been working on
this for two months okay thanks for
calling Mike what should you do when you
know more with more than your boss well
at first I think you should keep it to
yourself you know what sometimes you can
try to show it through your work and if
your boss can't see what you say if you
have a way that you think is better if
you just tell them that you know just
tell them directly it's almost like on
here it's like if we just offer advice
then it can be tricky but if we try not
for a suggestion like it's just a safer
way to do it so what I would suggest is
the first don't say don't say anything
just off the cuff and you have like a
real plan and - if you think it's a way
that you can help them actually
business-wise and save some money and if
they don't see it at first whatever your
method is or your means then maybe what
you need
you need to alter the way that you're
showing it to them and if you know that
they don'ts don't take you know just a
direct this is how to do it they're not
gonna like that then you need to just
show it to them in a way where maybe you
don't tell them at all
maybe you just show them repeatedly by
example and then let them suggest it
because they'll still get the same
outcome you'll still get the same
outcome too because then they just see
oh this person knows what they're doing
and they know how to take what I want
them to do and to do it better
they're still gonna know that they'll
know that but if you say oh this is how
to do it then they may hold it against
you and they may not you know and then
they may let you go and then just start
doing it your way with somebody else you
know they just might not be open to that
type of criticism so I think if they're
not seeing the better way that you're
showing them and then just try to find a
different way to show them but I would
show them instead of tell them that's
what I would try to do and I think that
that could be helpful and that's just a
suggestion dude also I don't know but
yeah people and we don't want to hear we
don't want to hear it we don't want to
hear that somebody knows better than us
a lot of times we don't want to hear
that own word thanks for calling Cody
let's hear more and when I feel
inadequate is when I have to take my car
to the mechanic oh yeah that [ __ ] can
make you really feel it's like a tall
child it always feels like I have to
take a test when you go in there because
it's like hey ma'am you know my car and
they're like what's wrong with it I
don't [ __ ] know because I'm not a
mechanic you know like I don't know [ __ ]
about mechanics like I'm a manly dude I
do man [ __ ] you know I've been in
Afghanistan deployment I got a family
thanks for your service bud homeward I
do think and I don't know anything about
cars so when I go in there I feel like
this guy's got one up on me you know
already and then
you never know how much it's going to
cause it's like waiting list like some
sort of AIDS test for your car when you
go back in there it might be a hundred
dollars it might be [ __ ] seven
hundred dollars yeah you don't know and
that's it you know that and that feels
you feel or I feel when I whenever that
when that happens I feel like I'm able
someone could really take advantage of
me
and that's not a good feeling how should
we approach the mechanic we don't know
[ __ ] you know that's a good question and
look we had a mechanic that called in
earlier you know that was Brian so maybe
he'll be able to if he hears this he'll
be able to send in a call and we'll put
it on next week next week's episode have
an answer but yeah if you're a consumer
with a car and you go to a mechanic how
do you get it right I mean here are some
things that I could suggest bro is that
you know I I had a police officer one
time was giving me a ticket oh he was
actually impounded they were taking my
car in because I had a bad play tonight
this and that and you know I hadn't
taken care of my responsibilities and so
this gentleman as he's writing it up and
he said they're coming to tow it and all
this I said look man I said I just want
you to know I said I wouldn't do this to
you that's what I told him and at first
he was being real you know he was maybe
that crazy dad I know who he was really
[ __ ] me [ __ ] me down bruh you know
proverbially [ __ ] me down and visibly
[ __ ] me down to some visible dicks
John John what is that Oh invisible kegs
but but then when I said to him I said
look man I wouldn't do this to you I
said I'm having a tough time right now
you know I don't have any money I'm over
here for a work meeting I'm trying to
get a little bit of a leg up and I know
I didn't take care of my
responsibilities but you take this car
away man you know I need to fly out
tonight to the airport it's just gonna
put me in a really tough position and I
said I wouldn't do this to you and he
still took my car away but when I got to
the police station to get it out to
impound it he already had all the
paperwork done and the other officer
there said wow I don't know what you
guys talked about but he never does this
you know I'm amazed that they have is
done usually it's a day or something or
whatever before they get this paperwork
in and I don't know if they had enough
but I was just really honest with the
guy and so maybe that's the you know
what if you went in there and said look
you know I'm uh you know my budgets are
tight I have two children
you know you know I work off of a GI
Bill you know I'm going through school I
was a service member whatever and I
don't know anything about mechanicing
you know
now if ways that I could help you or if
you asked me about this if you asked me
about hand-to-hand combat you ask me
about what weapons should I purchase
safely to per try to try and protect my
family if you ask me about you know
what's the best way to stay cool and in
the Afghanistan summer you know those
are things you'd be able to help him
with but just say hey you know these are
things I do know and what I don't know
is mechanicing and I know and I don't
know that I can afford to be just
screwed over so I'm asking you just
man-to-man
you know how much does this cost and
just just know that if you came to me
and I was a mechanic and you were a
customer that I would treat you a
hundred percent fairly and if that's
true and you would then he'll I think
he'll feel that and if you still get an
uncomfortable feeling and trust your gut
trust that bringing your gut baby boy
you got that admit that you know that
MIM belly that's Sara belly and I think
that's it sometimes just lay it out
straight look here's Who I am be
vulnerable here's Who I am this is my
scenario I don't have a million dollars
I can't you know and I don't know about
mechanicing but I need some help here
I just need you to know that this is
where I am and I wouldn't take advantage
of you and sometimes when you put it
like that to people it takes it out of
that business thing and it puts it into
a human thing and then they feel better
instead of making more money if they
have any sort of heart they feel better
about making more esteem for themselves
because they're not gonna screw you over
they're gonna do something esteem Abul
they're gonna do something kind you know
cause esteem of will people do esteem
Abul things but that's just a suggestion
man but good luck out there I hate that
feeling but we can't know it all
and sometimes we have to be vulnerable
and just assume that the guy's gonna
treat us well a good look Cody thank you
for that let's take out another call
here hey okay ain't Amy from Saudi
Arabia thank you for calling I have been
dealing with depression and anxiety to
maybe seven eight months
Wow I'm sorry to hear that
yeah it's hectic I can't imagine
especially in Saudi Arabia where it can
be really hot you know anxiety and
depression aren't fun and they're
definitely not fun when it's really hot
outside let's hear more but I can't
visit OC here because you know they're
very expensive and must have hurt they
are very bad okay so she can't see or
hear a therapist there because they are
very expensive from what she's heard
very bad more honestly I don't know but
maybe you can give me an advice for
something that will make this more
bearable because I had suicidal thoughts
for for quite a while now and I still
question why why would someone keep on
going when life is pretty [ __ ] and yeah
it can be very bad here
I mean it's Saudi Arabia that explains a
lot
not a friendly country for women
especially not for everyone and they
just want to say it because to yourself
to feel I really appreciate everything
you do you're very awesome thank you
thank you and Amy or Annie I'm sorry I
couldn't hear that part for Colin you
know what's funny as you're saying this
in this call I'm thinking like well what
if this is my mother calling you know
what if that was my mother or my sister
you know calling a phone number in
another country to share how they felt
and it makes me you know if it makes me
feel well I love you
you know you so don't feel alone I don't
want you to feel that I can imagine I
you know when you said it's very tough
there in Saudi Arabia yeah I mean you
know we always hear that in the news I
mean I've been to Saudi Arabia before
and seen you know the men walking had
like three or four women like dressed up
walking behind them and it's you know it
has a very what appeared to me and that
look I was just there in the airport I
think twice to have like a very like
subservient type of vibe I can imagine
that that yeah we're you know we don't
even think about that where do you get
mental health help in a place like that
well for one you're reaching out to
others so that's really positive and you
have a beautiful voice and you're not
alone you know we have we have a lot of
mental health problems here in America
so we have that in common you know you
know I don't really know how to help
cure your depression I do know a couple
things that taking a different contrary
action can help so if you get up in the
morning you lay there for an extra half
hour and you don't feel good then then
you know that's gonna happen if that
happens every day you know that's gonna
happen so you have to do something
contrary to that you have to get up
right out of bed even though you don't
want to and take a walk or listen to a
song that you like or stretch or smile
or sometimes I started doing this new
thing where I think about I think about
something silly or stupid that I do you
know I think about something silly or
stupid that I do personally and I laugh
at myself and that puts me in a lot of
different perspective when I can do that
when I can laugh at myself at the
beginning of the day because then I'm
not taking myself so seriously
you can you have to take but yeah I I
you know one thing that helps me is
taking contrary action you know I know I
don't want to go to the gym or to yoga
and so I do it anyway because if I do it
anyway then I start to train myself to
do something different than the previous
actions which have led me all to the
same spot to be caught up in my anxiety
and caught up in my depression because
depression will tell you to not do
anything that's one of the depressions
main weapons oh don't don't do anything
you feel bad you know feelings aren't
facts feelings are not facts and you can
if you take a if you take a contrary
action you take an action your feelings
will follow there's no way you can go
for a walk and not feel a little better
then whenever you started the wall
there's no way this fact that's a walk
fact that's a walk fact dub F's so you
know those are some things but the cool
thing is that I'm just now remembering
is we have a guy named christopher ryan
coming in who wrote a book called sex at
dawn he's a psychologist so he knows
more than me in this area for sure
I mean I've certainly been a victim of
anxiety and depression I certainly know
that that [ __ ] grows on itself like a
moss and if you stay indoors and you
don't get outdoors and you don't get in
the sunlight and you don't let the
higher powers of the world see you and
see that you're a good person and you
stay caught up and you stay cloaked
inside you know and you stay inside of
your bubble of nothing can change then
it then it's a petri dish for depression
and anxiety and that stuff just grows on
itself until it's just a dark vine and
it's living on the side of your face and
it's one of its songs of one of its you
know tentacles has just gone in your ear
and every time your brain wants to have
a good idea just chokes it out chokes it
out a little bit so you have to take
some contrary action so that's something
that's helped me so that's something
that's just an idea but we're get I'll
ask him I'll play this call for him and
I'll ask him when he's in here so we can
get you a little bit of actual somebody
who's certified with a
more education a lot more education and
I hear that he's a really great soul as
well
he's been on Joe Rogan's podcast and
he's the best he's a best friend of one
of my best friends so we'll play that
for him
Amy or Annie I couldn't hear your name
but just know that you're not alone and
people love you you know you I don't
know if you know that but I never
thought in my life about how many women
might be suffering with mental health
disorders in Saudi Arabia and you just
open my eyes up to that so I'm a little
a little upset by that because now
that's something that I have to think
about but I'm also grateful because you
know once we start to get better from
some of our ailments I feel like we have
a responsibility to try and help others
get better you know but keep your head
up all right young lady
go for a walk and just know that we're
thinking about you we're talking about
you right now
and that that's cool right it's cool all
right be good let's hear another
question here I do I'm a student I'm
starting school on the 4th of June
there's just so much going on and so
much changing in the world and I'm just
always I always feel like I just I
always feel like things could be better
I guess I just feel like I could be I
could always feel better I could always
be better better better better you know
and it's just like and like but mmm I
don't even know man all right I love you
man but thanks for calling that's
exhausting isn't it it's exhausting
feeling like things can always be better
things can always feel better better
better better yeah Wow as you say that
man I can relate to that so much you
know I spent and I spill spend half of
my day thinking about that you know
instead of just being grateful for what
at where I am you know I'm being
grateful that things are better things
are
things are better than when I used to
stand around his put press in my hands
against my hips thinking I had him in my
pockets you know things are better you
know now when I'm able to like I'm able
to sit here and think about all with
other people about their issues instead
of just being stuck in my own you know
things are better you know things are
better when you know I'm able to go home
and and you know be upset by something
that you know my mother didn't do on
purpose that is just inadvertent but it
reminded me of all these feelings of how
like my mother was never available to me
but now I know that that that time is
over and she doesn't feel it that way
she doesn't know it that way you know
all she knows is that she loves me now
and that and that she's always loved me
and so whatever pain or whatever I have
from previous there's nothing I can so
all I can do now is just be patient and
just just you know just let her know
that I care no matter what and try not
to in it you don't start a new grudge
and that's better than I used to be you
know it's it's wild man because you do
get better and you know one thing that
does help me and this is something that
I do every day is make a gratitude list
when I'm wake up in the morning I make a
gratitude list and I list ten things
that I'm grateful for
and then I list a reason why with each
one you know I'm grateful for my hair
why because it keeps my head warm and my
neck warm now at this point or I'm
grateful for my sister because she never
gives up and she tries so hard and you
know we're I'm grateful for I'm grateful
for my mother my mother because she's
still alive you know I'm grateful for my
friend beau
because I went home this weekend and he
let me borrow his truck so that I cuz I
don't have my driver's license I
couldn't get a rental car and he made my
weekend so much easier where he gave me
the opportunity I could go see my nieces
and and and it was a gift you know I'm
grateful there's just and you know what
it does though it takes it so now I'm
not thinking about me and I'm not
thinking about what could be better I'm
thinking about what is good and so for
me that works man I'm not trying to be a
know-it-all or anything I'm just telling
you that works I still have a ton of
moments where I think things could be
better but also some of that came from
when I was young you know something was
somebody around me nothing was ever good
enough for them and so then that builds
in me that old things always have to be
better but man I bet you're doing ok you
know if you try and look at the facts
you know try and look at the facts are
you doing okay because it may be that
thing that should be better me that
could just be a feeling you know in
feelings aren't facts
I think feelings are way important you
know I'd rather know how I feel
sometimes and what I think but feelings
aren't facts man and if you get always
getting that feeling than you
you know maybe find some ways and up for
me a gratitude list helps because then I
quit thinking about you know what I
don't have and what could be better and
I think about what I do have and that
puts me in a place of gratitude from me
and also might not know what the [ __ ]
I'm talking about let's take one last
call here and then we're gonna shut it
down for today man I appreciate all you
guys calling appreciate everything nine
eight five six six four nine five zero
three is the hotline Theo von comm slash
store we got a bunch of dope merch in
there and cool stuff if you want to
support the podcast or support anything
Theo von comm slash patreon that's where
we have funds where we can do outreach
and do some other neat stuff we're gonna
do some stuff for these single moms if
there's a date we have coming up on the
calendar where we're gonna be in your
area and there's a cool single mother
that you know that you think could use a
night out and I don't want some lady you
know if she got 40 year old children or
35 I want to I want somebody that's you
know still in the trenches that's got
them you know chirping mouths you know
out of 12 year old on a your you know
you know what I'm and I'm not trying to
ice anybody out of the opportunity but
you know I ain't trying to take you know
grandma girdle and her two shorties out
to the to the ice to a comedy show you
know when she got a fifty year old son
and he ain't getting his [ __ ] together
that's that's on him you know we're just
trying to get a little bit of relief a
nice evening for a lady or two but you
can submit them through the website Theo
von comm slash podcast or podcasts it's
all on the website let's take this call
here we go
thank you for calling hey what's up CEO
Andy and Portland Oregon hey Andy in
Portland and you know well you know I
met a hamster rancher up there and we
went and visited him and man that was
awesome man I went and saw this man had
about five six thousand hams and we had
them beautiful critters and everybody
was just hmm man beautiful to see all
those magical little just nuggets of the
Lord just those furry living electrons
just some of them [ __ ] and peep some
a lot of them just sleeping and resting
and everything so watch them just set it
off let's hear more I just wanted to say
what's up I know things are going to be
blowing up for you soon I just wanted to
send you a friendly reminder as you're
on the precipice of success just
remember who you are brother that's why
people love you
don't get tempted by the dark arts don't
fall into traps just keep being you
don't sell out my man much love I love
you and not in a homosexual way I just
love what you're doing with your life
and no understand that part
homeward your life and the way you're
staying true and the podcast and your
comedy man alright later thanks Andy for
the message man I appreciate it
I really do and you know I not thought
about that actually a lot in the past
two weeks like you know there has been a
lot there has been an uptick and like
support people reaching out you know I
notice it at the
shows you know even at the Comedy Store
like people wanting to hang out at you
know take pictures and things like that
and you know I worry a lot about ego you
not worry about it because it's
dangerous my ego is so dangerous isn't
it it's roms remarkable there's
something inside of us that is just so
abhi that I thought that that's the dark
arts it's so upset it's so I mean it's
so mystical that's a shape-shifter that
thing is just wiggling and in and out of
your in and out of your brainstem just
you know just circling you're you're
Sarah you're all just circling your
brainstem just waiting just waiting this
to speak up and it's scary man I think
about it sometimes I appreciate you
saying that yeah I mean I do want to you
know I do want to achieve my goals but
at the same time I do feel like I want
to you know I want to you know I don't
want to be self-centered you know I've
spent so you know because the worst part
about I've spent a lot of my life being
self-centered even though some people
might not say that to me it felt that
way because I just had to care about
myself you know when you're growing up
and you feel like you don't have anybody
then you become self-centered almost as
a mechanism to take care of yourself you
know you have to be so aware of
everything you have to be on guard all
the time you have to be thinking how do
I get what I need because it just
started as such an age where you that's
all it just it's you had to use it to
survive it was like learning to drink
water you had to have that skill you had
to have that you know that me me me me
because if nobody else cared about you
or that's how you saw it then you had to
care about yourself because if you
didn't care about you then there would
be no one who did
and so you know but I know as I've
gotten older that I can shed that skin
and that that doesn't serve me the same
anymore
but I'd but it's remarkable the ego is
so powerful you know and it's tricky and
it's cunning and it's baffling and it's
powerful and that's copy RIT and I know
but you know it is and I don't want to
you know I don't want to but I
appreciate that reminder and if I seem
out of line many check me because I'm
happy to be checked you know I don't
want to I want to do you don't want to
do good things I want to I want to I
want to achieve my goals but I want to
do good things too you know I don't want
to leave the earth when I get out of
here and just you know not have a like a
lot of love in my life you know and just
a lot of joy because in the end
especially as I get older being selfish
just it starts to hurt a lot it hurts
I think it hurts because all you have at
some points when you're so selfish all
you really have and the you know it is
you and that's just so lonely it's just
lonely but I appreciate you checking me
man and you can do it again if you feel
that way Andy
you'll be the ego lifeguard if that's ok
with you but you know and I know I'm not
the only one out there that thinks this
way about our egos and how dangerous it
can be I worry about it I worry about it
but I appreciate you uh you know let me
know I'm not alone in thinking about it
and thanks for the kind words man you
know I don't know what the you know what
the future has in store for me
career-wise but man this this year has
been great and we're and being a part of
this podcast has been great I mean gee I
never thought this podcast would be up
like this dude this thing look at the
front mean we were balancing I was
balancing that camera on [ __ ] shoe
boxes yeah I mean it was so it's just
been a joy and we're gonna do some cool
stuff we're gonna do it together and I
appreciate you guys being here with me
all right I'm gonna take us out here
on this Memorial Day happy Memorial Day
to everyone thank you for everybody to
hit the hotline thank you for everybody
that's being supportive if you have any
suggestions constructive criticisms you
can always hit us up anywhere you know
this is a team effort we do this and
some weeks these episodes will be what
you want in someone because these
episodes will be not what you want but
that's life so stick around and let's
make this thing let's let's keep this
thing alive together a happy Memorial
Day
[Music]
you